we did this to you we thought we were  helping you a ripped from the headlines  feature I know what schools are looking  for and how to get you to check those  blocks inspired by true events you  studied Darwin last year didn't you yes  some species survive and some doubt -  desperate mothers I will teach you how  to make an impression we'll do anything  he's losing his way involved in a  nationwide scandal you are worth every  penny of the five million dollars that  we paid you you do such great work for  so many people there must be something  you can do  there are things one thing in particular  actually sterling Penelope Ann Miller  and be a Kershner money laundering real  consequences Vegas at t speaks sports  for months and months though you  happening to notice am I gonna be  arrested to the College Admission  scandal from here Saturday October 12th  at 8:00 on lifetime  [Music]